okay everyone who wants to help me
destroy my enemies raise your hand great
will conquer the world
right after I rant about chappy and the
taxonomy of movie robots on this week's
episode of angry nerd first your
comments a Drock one responded to my top
ten movies of 2014 list with this but
wait Michael Bay released a new
Transformers movie shouldn't it be on
here at Rock I'm worried about you are
you on some illicit substance do you
need me to talk you down or call poison
control the new robot movie chappie
makes me furious the odd capitalization
scheme of the title that isn't it looks
like the name of a valley startup but
everything else about Neill Blomkamp's
new flick looks hopefully boss chappie
stars a computer-generated droid and the
trailer proves how much better the CG
design is implemented than in Will
Smith's I Robot ah
they forgot Asimov's a flaw movie robots
should not hate the aesthetic of first
gen IMAX I also like the chappies hero
does battle with the tiresome roles that
robots have generally been relegated to
by Hollywood you see there are three
species of movie robots
yeah the cutesy servant droids who
perform repairs and dispense comic
relief then you add the menacing heavies
bad guys designed to inflict pain and
yes
Mechagodzilla counts as a robot and
finally you have the robot as childlike
named steel Pinocchio's who gradually
learn about the wonders and horrors of
the world Hollywood movies are dominated
by the first two types but the last one
it's clearly best these characters are
much more involving and relatable and
movies can use the unique perspective of
these BOTS to reflect on what it means
to be human
yeah
we need more movies to cast robots as
the wide-eyed outsider but the only way
we'll get those is if robot actors
refuse to take the over-familiar
stereotyped roles I'm talking to you
Jeff 1000 what wire property I don't
care if it's a wired show that droid is
a 10-ton sellout how do you sleep at
night Jeff 1000 or how what do you sleep
if you're a biological entity that
required sleep hey hey are you running
an annotation to Jeff 1000 over me right
now knock it off I'm not gonna
cross-promote for that I gotta say I'm a
little worried about the fact that the
robot in chappie
apparently learns how to be human from
the goony bird members of the RAF group
two on four I question their credentials
what is there a backroom deal between
Guam camp the Cape Town Chamber of
Commerce to promote fellow South African
artists yeah seriously learning how to
be human from ninja and Yolandi is like
learning to write a satisfying third act
from M night Shyamalan what's your
favorite movie robot let me know in the
comments and subscribe to the wired
Channel watch my other videos over there
robot henchmen can you point to my other
videos there I knew that you could dance
a Cabbage Patch for me duh that's not
the Cabbage Patch no here go over here
go over
attack that comic book just point point
point yeah I knew that you could can we
can we get some tape for him it's just
it's not hitting his mark